Und bevor Sie mich über Ihre Beschwerden erzählen, möchte ich ganz schnell auch ein paar allgemeine Fragen zu Ihrer Verwünschung stellen.
Okay? Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Felix Kosche.
Felix?
Felix Kosche.
Kosche. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen bestabilen?
Kosche schreibt sich K-O-S-C-H-E. Kosche.
Okay. Herr Kosche. Wie alt sind Sie?
63 Jahre.
63. Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 24. Juli 1959.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,79 m groß und wiege 83 kg.
83. Okay. Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, wenn verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Wahrscheinlich Erwachsene Kinder.
Ja, 31 Jahre und 34 Jahre.
Sehr gut. Und was sind Sie von der Beruf?
Ich bin von Beruf Gertner.
Gertner.
Okay.
Ja, Sie arbeiten Sie noch?
Ja, ich arbeite noch ein Jahr und dann gehe ich in Ruhrstand.
Okay.
Herr Kosche. Was führt Sie zu und was tut bestärken haben Sie im Moment?
Ja, ich habe seit zwei Tagen habe ich zunehmende Bauchschmerzen.
Die begannen ziemlich gering, aber sie wurden dann jetzt immer stärker,
die Bauchschmerzen.
Und jetzt sind sie so stark, da habe ich gesagt,
jetzt muss ich jetzt Krankenhaus.
Ja, Sie haben sich sehr gut entschieden.
Ja, wo sind die Schmerzen am stärksten?
Ja, kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen, der Bauch ist ziemlich aufgebläht
und er tut eigentlich überall weh.
Ganzes Bauch.
Ja.
Okay.
Seit zwei Tagen.
Ja, aber er ist jetzt immer schlimmer geworden, immer mehr, immer stärker.
Haben Sie etwas probiert um die Schmerzen zu finden?
Ich habe mal eine Wärmflasche auf den Bauch gelegt, aber das war nicht gut.
War nicht gut.
Ich habe es nicht mehr gemacht.
Okay.
Ich gehe heute.
Und,
konnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben, genau beschreiben,
sind Sie eher drücken, sticheln, ziehen?
Ja, ist mehr so ein drückender Schmerz
und der läuft so wellenförmig, der kommt und geht
aber er ist nie ganz weg.
Aber wenn er wieder kommt, dann wird er ganz stark.
Wenn ich nicht falsch verstanden habe, sind Ihre Schmerzen
nicht dauerhaft.
Doch, Sie sind immer da, Sie sind immer da, aber dann werden Sie plötzlich ganz stark.
Und dann geht wieder etwas zurück, aber es bleibt immer ein Schmerz.
Okay.
Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz gelaufen?
Wenn ein sehr leckerer Schmerz ist, dann ist es ein unerträglicher Schmerz.
Ich würde sagen, wenn der Schmerz leicht ist, ist er sechs.
Und wenn so eine Welle kommt, dann ist er neun.
Zwischen sechs und neun.
Jetzt haben Sie stark Schmerzen.
Ich habe eine starke Welle.
Und jetzt wird es langsam wieder besser, aber er ist immer noch da der Schmerz.
Er geht nie ganz weg.
Okay.
Ich habe da auch noch eine starke Welle.
Und hatten Sie früher ähnliche Schmerzen?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Das ist ganz neu.
Okay.
Strahlende Schmerzen, irgendwo hinauf?
In den Rücken?
Ja, ein bisschen vielleicht in den Rücken, aber nicht so schlimm.
Hauptsache, Sie sind mehr vorne im Bauch.
Sie strahlen nicht aus.
Okay.
Haben Sie Piva?
Nein, aber mir ist etwas, ich muss etwas schwitzen.
Gerade wenn die Schmerzen so stark sind, dann schwitze ich etwas.
Aber Schüttelfrost-Piva habe ich nicht.
Kalte Schwitzen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Kalte Schwitzen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut, aber seitdem ich diese Schmerzen habe,
ist er nicht gut.
Mir ist auch etwas übel, aber ich habe bisher nicht gebrochen.
Aber mir ist übel.
Sie haben nicht erbrücken.
Herr Küche, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewöldstarkt abgenommen?
Nein, ich habe in den letzten zwei Monaten schon Gewicht abgenommen,
so 4 kg.
40, ungefähr 4 kg habe ich abgenommen.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wieso.
Ich habe beim Essen nichts geändert.
Ich habe in der letzten Zeit 2 Monate abgenommen.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Die letzten beiden Nächte habe ich wegen der Schmerzen nicht gut geschlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen keinen Stuhlgang gehabt.
Sie haben verstopfen.
Das letzte Mal war ich auf der Toilette vor 3 Tagen.
Gibt es etwas, dass diese Schmerzen ausgelöst?
Schlimmert?
Ja, am Anfang.
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen ausgelöst hat?
Ich weiß nicht.
Irgendwann waren die Schmerzen abends.
Ich habe in Fußball gesehen und plötzlich kamen diese Bauchschmerzen.
Aber sie wurden langsam stärker.
Sie waren nicht gleich von Anfang an so stark.
Sie wurden in den letzten nächsten Stunden immer stärker.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen,
von denen ich bezogen habe, wie Blutdruck, Diabetes?
Ja, ich habe etwas hohen Blutdruck.
Seit ca. 12 Jahren.
Ich nehme auch Medikamente ein.
Ich nehme einen Amlodipin.
Das steht hinter 5.
Amlodipin 5.
Ich nehme abends eine Tablette.
Nehmen Sie noch irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ja, dann nehme ich noch einen Blutdruckmittel ein.
Kann die Satanen.
Da steht hinter 8.
8 Milligramm.
Ja, dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Ich nehme noch eine Tablette ein.
Hohe Blutfette.
Das ist schwierig auszusprechen.
Das heißt Rosu-Vastatin.
Ich nehme noch eine Tablette ein.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette ein.
Seit wann haben Sie erhöht Blutfette?
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich mal operiert.
Da hatte ich einen Nabelbruch,
am Bauchnabel, einen Bruch.
Da wurde ich operiert, da war ich so 6 Jahre alt.
Und dann hatte ich nochmal eine Operation am Blinddarm.
Da war ich 11 Jahre alt.
Okay, herrlich.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auch in irgendwelchen Medikamente?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Ich habe bisher immer alles vertragen.
Okay, sind Sie vorstern mit Ihnen?
Ja, mein Hausarzt sagte, das war jetzt vor einem Jahr.
Ich hätte alle Impfungen.
Und ich habe jetzt auch drei Impfungen gegen Corona.
Sehr gut.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ja, ich war mal auf Mallorca.
Vor ungefähr acht Wochen, ne, zehn Wochen war ich auf Mallorca.
Für eine Woche aber nur.
Sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Und gibt es vor sechs Wochen?
Ja, vor zehn Wochen.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich gerne über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten
pratenstellen.
Rauchen Sie Herr Poche?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke Abendbrote, eine Flasche Bier.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie nicht rauchwerend sind.
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Okay, wer?
Hatten Sie mit dem Drogen einen Kontakt?
Mit Drogen.
Ja, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ich habe noch nie einen Kontakt.
Mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, Herr Poche.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, der Vater, der ist mit 75 Jahren verstorben.
Der hatte Darmkrebs.
Ihre Mutter?
Die Mutter, die lebt noch, die ist jetzt 85 Jahre alt.
Die hatte aber auch schon einen Schlaganfall.
Und hat hohen Blutdruck.
Aber sie lebt noch.
Im welchem Jahr hatte sie einen Schlaganfall?
Ja, das ist jetzt schon bestimmt 10 Jahre her, 10, 15 Jahre her.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 61 Jahre alt, der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie zwei Kinder haben.
Ja.
Sie sind gesund.
Okay.
Leben Sie mit Ihrer Frau?
Ja, wir wohnen zusammen.
Die Kinder wohnen nicht mehr bei uns.
Die haben eigene Familien.
Okay.
eigene Haus?
Die Kinder haben eigene Familien, die wohnen auch in einer anderen Stadt.
Leben Sie in einer Wohnung oder in einem Haus?
Ja, wir leben in einer Wohnung.
Okay.
Herr Koche, treiben Sie Sport?
Nein.
Der Beruf als Gärtner, der ist schon sehr anstrengend.
Und da mache ich keinen Sport.
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Viel fettig.
Oder ernähren Sie sich ausgewogen?
Ja, ich esse schon Fleisch.
So drei Mal in der Woche esse ich Fleisch.
Und meine Frau, die sagt immer, wir müssen mehr Gemüse essen.
Ja.
Sie hat recht.
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie weniger gleich sind.
Genau.
Aber wenn ich auf der Arbeit bin, dann essen wir mal gerne in der
Mittagspause auch mal etwas Pomfritt.
Oder eine Bratwurst.
Ich weiß, dass das nicht so gesund ist, aber ja, das machen wir halt.
Gib Ratem.
Herr Koche, ich habe alle meine richtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hin?
Jetzt kommt gerade wieder so eine Welle von Schmerz.
Was glauben Sie denn, was das ist, was ich habe?
Herr Koche,
als Erste haben immer drei Schritte um eine richtige Diagnose
gestellt zu können.
Zuerst an einem Nese gespielt, dann eine körpferliche Unterdrückung
und operative Diagnostik.
Ja, ich habe einen Verdacht auf eine
Diagnose.
Polistisch.
Ja, Patientin Sprache.
Ich habe vergessen.
Wo kann es sein, in welchem Organ?
Was ist, was ist nicht in Ordnung?
Ja, ja, jetzt.
Ja, ja, Galbenblasen, Galbenblasen-Entstündung.
Ja, ich habe einen Verdacht auf eine Galbenblasen-Entstündung.
Und da Galbenblasen-Steine.
Aber das muss man bestätigt werden.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe.
Ich werde mit meinem Oberarzt sprechen, wie wir weiter vorgehen.
Ich komme gleich zurück.
Okay, okay.
5 Minuten oder kürzer?
Ja, ich habe ein paar Fragen.
Ich möchte gerne ein paar Fragen stellen.
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, ihr euch schmerzen seit Beginn nicht zu gang gehen.
Ich würde gerne wissen, seit Beginn ihr euch schmerzen gehen, Gas ab.
Nicht so richtig.
Ich habe jetzt mal den Eindruck, ich muss mehr Luft aufstoßen.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass ich seit zwei Tagen gelblich geworden bin?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, ich lasse Wasser. Welche Probleme?
Wasser lassen kann ich eigentlich normal ganz gut.
Ich muss regelmäßig einmal in der Nacht auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber sonst habe ich mit Wasser lassen keine Beschwerden.
Sie haben Blähungen gesagt.
Ja, etwas Blähungen.
Ja, der ganze Bauch ist dick.
Es schlug mich.
Mir ist übel.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ich vielleicht auch bald Brechreize bekomme.
Aber er ist mit dem Augenblick übel.
Ich mache nichts essen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe meine Frage.
Sind Sie bis jetzt endoskopiert worden?
Eine endoskopische Untersuchung ist bei Ihnen durchgeführt worden?
Ich habe bisher noch keine Vorsorgeuntersuchung machen lassen.
Mein Hausarzt rät mir dazu.
Ich soll das jetzt machen lassen, weil ich so in dem Alter bin.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, dass ich das jetzt Ende des Jahres machen lassen möchte.
Aber bis jetzt habe ich das noch nicht gemacht.
Ab 55 Jahre kommt eine Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Meine Frau sagt auch immer, ich soll das machen lassen.
Aber bis jetzt habe ich es noch nicht gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Hättest du Zeit für mich?
Ich möchte über einen neuen Patienten erzählen.
Ja, bitte.
Herr Felix Koche ist ein 63-jähriger Patient.
Er ist 1,79 m groß und 83 kg schwer.
Er stammt sich seit 2 Tagen besonder und plötzlich aufgetreten.
Er hat eine Abdominelle Schmerzen.
Er hat eine Warnflasche probiert und die Schmerzen zu liegen.
Aber das es sich nicht besagt.
Er hat eine Obstipation.
Vor 2 Tagen.
Er hat eine Obstipation oder eine Stuhlgangverhalten?
Er sei im Alter von 6 Nabelbruch.
Unbilikalherne und appendectomy.
Voroperationen im Bauch.
Was gibt es in der Familie eine Aufhelligkeit?
Er ist in der Familie von Kolonkarcinon Baym Fatah.
Schlaganfall, Apoplex.
Er hat auch 2 Kinder.
Er ist in der Familie von Kolonkarcinon Baym Fatah.
Er hat eine gebratene Gegend.
Die Ernährung ist mitteleuropäisch.
Freischkonsum usw.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Sie haben auch viele Leute wegen Kololythiasis.
Wie bewerten Sie diese Gewichtsabnahme von 4 kg?
Die Gewichtsabnahme von 2 kg,
die Stuhlverhaltung von 2 kg,
die Stuhlverhaltung von 3 kg,
Verdacht auf ein Iliosich erhärten lässt.
Das kann man durch die klinische Untersuchung natürlich ausgultatorisch machen,
pylpatorisch, rektale Untersuchung.
Wahrscheinlich wird die Ampulle, Direktumampulle,
keinen Stuhl enthalten, die ist leer.
Zu fragen wäre der Patient noch, ob er irgendwelche Auffälligkeiten im Stuhl
in den letzten Wochen hatte.
Manchmal bericht die Patienten über schleimige Stühle,
nicht unbedingt glutig, schleimige Stühle oder dass der Stuhl insgesamt dünner ist.
Das wäre vielleicht noch in der Anameseerhebung ganz wichtig.
Ich glaube in diesem Falle nicht, dass es an der Galle liegt.
Ja.
Die schmecken,
seien in ganzen,
in ganzen Abdominen.
Genau.
Nicht so ganz typisch kollegartig, vielleicht bei einer Gallenkolleg.
Also ich denke, wir müssen auf alle Fälle jetzt
eine Dame abklären und schauen,
ist es ein Ilios, der akut auch behandlungsbedürftig ist?
Da müssen wir nach ein, zwei Stunden, wenn Sie die ersten Untersuchungen haben,
möchte ich den Patienten auch noch mal selber untersuchen.
Und je schlechter Alter Sprüchte für, ja, vor und nach.
Mit eine gewisse familiäre Vorgeschichte und und und,
da muss man, glaube ich, in der Richtung denken.
Aber wichtig ist jetzt erst mal eine, eine, eine Akutdiagnostik zu machen,
dieses Akutenabdomens.
Gut.
Okay.
Und Sie müssen immer wieder ein bisschen dran denken.
Die Umsetzung von der Patientensprache.
Ja, ja, ja.
Auf die Tessare habe ich extra mal die Nabelherne,
den Nabelbruch.
Manchmal.
Benommen unbilikalherne, ja, wichtig.
Herneutomie, oder OP,
einer unbilikalherne, keine Leisten.
Das ist ganz wichtig, dass Sie das mit,
vielleicht versuchen, einfließen zu lassen in diese Fachsprache.
Aber sonst haben Sie das, denke ich, systematisch gemacht.
Beim Stuhlgang hätte ich noch ein bisschen, wie gesagt,
ein bisschen genauer gefragt, ob das jetzt,
ja, ist das zum ersten Mal passiert?
Ich habe gesagt, das ist zum ersten Mal.
Aber dann würde ich einfach noch mal fragen, war der Stuhlgang
vielleicht in letzter Zeit etwas verändert?
Manchmal, wie gesagt, gibt es so Schleim im Stuhl
und dann sagen die Leute, ja, wenn Sie mich jetzt so fragen,
dann war das so, spontan berichten die Patienten das nicht immer.
Aber gut, es war ein bisschen schwieriger,
aber ich denke, gemeinsam kann man das lösen.
Wann haben Sie einen Prüfungstermin?
22, der Octobus.
Ja, gut, das sind ja noch jetzt fünf, sechs Wochen.
Dann können Sie das bis dahin versuchen,
noch ein bisschen in die medizinische Sprache zu werden.
Ja, ja, Fachbegriffe, ja.
Ich rufe die Fachbegriffe auf, Konstantiven.
Alles klar.